on me dit john zeng li en répondant au
nom de l'assemblée générale j'ai
l'honneur de souhaiter la bienvenue aux
nations unies elles son excellence
recep tayyip erdogan président de la
république de turquie
et je l'invite à s'adresser à
l'assemblée
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement monsieur le
secrétaire général
mesdames et messieurs les représentantes
et représentants
en mon nom propre et au nom de ma nation
je tiens à vous adresser mes plus
chaleureuses salutations
je souhaite que la 66e session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
soit bénéfique pour nos pays et
l'ensemble de l'humanité
je suis ravi d'être une fois encore à
l'assemblée générale après deux ans pour
m'adresser à vous
en effet en tant qu'humanité ces deux
dernières années nous avons réellement
traversée des heures douloureuses nous
avons perdu 4,6 millions de personnes y
compris des amis
des membres de nos familles êtres chers
pendant la pandémie locaux vides 19
considérée comme la pire crise sanitaire
de ce siècle
du siècle écoulé en dépit des efforts
déployés et des progrès réalisés en
matière de vaccination nous constatons
que les conséquences néfastes de la
pandémie perdure
c'est ainsi que se tient la 66e session
de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies je suis convaincu que les messages
de solidarité de coopération que nous
porterons ici
contribueront non seulement à soutenir
la lutte contre la pandémie mais aussi à
susciter l'espoir des milliards de
personnes qui vivent encore des temps
très difficiles
notre assemblée générale doit être
renforcée sorte que la communauté
internationale puisse contribuer de
manière plus efficace aux règlements de
ces enjeux mondiaux j'aimerais saisir
l'occasion qui m'est donnée de remercier
monsieur volkan boss pire
président de la soixante quinzième
session de l'assemblée générale pour
tout le travail réalisé dans ce sens je
suis convaincu que monsieur abdallah
chahid
qu'un récemment assumé la présidence de
la 66e session de l'assemblée générale
portera le flambeau qui lui a été
transmis vers des sommets plus haut
encore la turquie pour sa part
continuera de s'acquitter de ses
responsabilités de sorte que l'assemblée
générale puisse poursuivre ses activités
de la manière la plus efficace possible
je tiens aussi à cette occasion à
féliciter monsieur goûter rech qui une
fois encore assume les fonctions de
secrétaire général des nations unies je
lui souhaite les pleins succès
il est bon que l'assemblée générale de
cette année était organisée sous le
thème miser sur l'espoir pour renforcer
la résilience
j'aimerais avant tout chose rappeler un
fait
aussi difficile soit-il de l'entendre
malheureusement cette pandémie venu une
fois encore nous rappeler que
le monde appartient une seule et même
grande famille
mais malheureusement
ce monde n'a pas passé avec succès le
test de la solidarité
les pays les plus sous-développées les
segments les plus pauvres de la société
ont été littéralement abandonné à leur
sort face à la pandémie les structures
biaisée du système mondial qui crée des
problèmes plutôt qu'ils ne trouvent des
solutions est venu aggraver ces
problèmes les condamnant à rester sans
solution
ce système a aussi sa part de
responsabilité dans ces pertes en vies
humaines alors que des millions de
personnes ont perdu la vie que des
dizaines de millions de personnes
souffrent en proie au virus c'est une
honte pour l'humanité que le
nationalisme des vaccins
se poursuivent de différentes manières
il est clair qu'une catastrophe mondiale
tels que la pandémie de colis 19 ne peut
être surmontée que par la coopération et
la solidarité internationale
aucun pays ne peut survivre et être en
sécurité
seul tant que tous les pays ne seront
pas libérés de la pandémie
nous espérons que la volonté dont nous
allons faire montre à l'assemblée
générale pour être un tournant et nous
permettent de comprendre
ce fait outre l'importance de la
coopération mondiale pendant la pandémie
nous constatons que la science médicale
atteint des niveaux
sans précédent
nous sommes fiers que le premier vaccin
approuvé par l' oms est été mise au
point par deux scientifiques d'origine
turque vivante en allemagne
la turquie s'est efforcé de partager les
capacités à sa disposition avec nos
frères et soeurs du monde entier depuis
le premier jour
dans l'autre dans le droit fil de notre
croyance qui dit que les sons les gens
vivre pour que l'état puisse vivre
tout en fournissant les meilleurs
services de santé possible à nos
citoyens nous avons envoyé de l'aide
médicale à 159 pays et 12 organisations
internationales
j'aimerais saisir l'occasion qui m'est
donnée de vous informer que nous allons
dans un avenir proche proposer notre
vaccin national baptisé turcot vaque à
l'ensemble de l'humanité
en plus de notre pays soutenons les
initiatives visant à renforcer
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et à
la bord et une convention contre les
pandémies nous insistons aussi en
particulier sur le fait que l'on devrait
trouver un juste équilibre entre la
protection de la santé publique et le
maintien de la vie sociale et économique
il amusé michel représentantes et
représentants
les événements dont nous sommes témoins
viennent nous rappeler encore certaines
réalités
nos joies tout comme nos tristesses nos
souffrances comme nos succès nos
problèmes tout comme les solutions
sont communs et communes
lorsque quelqu'un agit dans un esprit de
fait accompli c'est toute l'humanité qui
en paye le prix pas uniquement les plus
grands pays
nous avons vu en afghanistan pétri de
douleur que les problèmes ne peuvent pas
être réglés en imposant des solutions
qui ne tiennent pas compte des réalités
du tissu social sur le terrain
le peuple afghan a été abandonnée
en proie aux conséquences de
l'instabilité de conflit durant depuis
plus de quarante années
indépendamment du processus politique
l'afghanistan a besoin de l'aide et de
la solidarité de la communauté
internationale
nous espérons que la paix la stabilité
et la sécurité pourront être établies
dans le pays dans les plus brefs délais
et que le peuple afghan pourra trouver
secours la turquie pour sa part
continuera de s'acquitter de son devoir
fraternelle vis-à-vis du peuple afghan
en ces heures difficiles
dix années se sont écoulées depuis le
début de la catastrophe humanitaire en
syrie qui a entraîné la mort de
centaines de milliers de personnes et le
déplacement de millions d'autres au vu
et au su du monde entier
alors que notre pays
accueille près de 4 millions de syriens
il lui aussi sur le terrain contre les
organisations terroristes qui ont plongé
la région dans le sang et les larmes
nous sommes le seul allié de l'otan qui
est combattue dahesh au corps à corps et
vaincu cette organisation terroriste
fois encore grâce à notre présence sur
le terrain nous avons pu stopper les
massacres le nettoyage ethnique
imputable aux émanations de
l'organisation terroriste du pkk en
syrie grâce à ses efforts aux dépens de
nos martyrs nous avons pu garantir le
retour volontaire de 460
2006 rien
dans les zones où nous leur assurons la
sécurité
dans le même ordre d'idée grâce à notre
présence est libre nous avons sauvé la
vie de millions de personnes et empêcher
leur déplacement la communauté
internationale
ne saurait permettre que la crise
syrienne traîne encore pendant une
dizaine et supplémentaires nous de vous
faire montre de plus de volonté de
trouver une solution politique à ce
problème sur la base de la résolution 22
54 du conseil de sécurité des nations
unies et de manière à satisfaire les
attentes du peuple syrien
nous nous félicitons de la prorogation
du mécanisme d'assistance humanitaire
des nations unies
lequel est acheminée dans le nord-ouest
de la syrie via la turquie prorogation
pour une durée de 12 mois
supplémentaires
nous espérons
que
l' approche conciliante
dont nous faisons montre fera des émules
et permettra d'aboutir à un processus
politique
de garantir le retour volontaire sûr et
dans la dignité des demandeurs d'asile
j'aimerais une fois encore
répété devant vous qui établirent un
distinguo entre les organisations
terroristes dans la région les utiliser
comme sous traitants dans la région est
inacceptable
les actes de terrorisme dans différents
pays du monde ces dix dernières années
nous ont montré que le terrorisme n'est
pas seulement notre ennemi commun mais
qu'il est aussi l'ennemi de toute
l'humanité notre lutte contre les
organisations terroristes qui menacent
l'intégrité territoriale de la syrie et
notre sécurité nationale se poursuivra
avec détermination
dans notre pays à l'exception des
syriens nous comptons aussi des migrants
jouissant de différents statuts leur
nombre dépasse actuellement le millions
du fait de l'évolution de la situation
en afghanistan
nous sommes confrontés au risque de voir
affluer de nouveaux migrants en
provenance de ce pays en tant que pays
qui à préserver la dignité humaine
pendant la crise syrienne nous n'avons
plus les moyens
la capacité
d'absorber
une nouvelle vague de migrants sur la
base du partage des responsabilités et
du fardeau il est plus que temps que
toutes les parties prenantes
interviennent et assument leur part de
la responsabilité
nous devons nous opposer à ceux qui
sapent la convention de genève de 1951
et le droit international humanitaire
mesdames et messieurs les représentantes
et représentants
grâce à notre soutien sans faille à la
légitimité internationale en libye à
cesser le feu cessez le feu était
déclaré le conseil de la présidence et
le gouvernement d'unité nationale ont
été constitués nous continuerons de
soutenir les efforts du gouvernement
d'unité nationale pour fournir des
services publics unifier toutes les
institutions et organiser des élections
opportune
je réitère l'appel lancé à la communauté
internationale
pour qu'elle soutienne le gouvernement
légitime représentant toutes les régions
de la libye
un des principaux problèmes qui alimente
l'instabilité menace la paix et la
sécurité dans la région et le conflit
israélo palestinien
tant que le peuple palestinien sera
persécutés la paix et la stabilité
durable au moyen-orient seront
impossibles c'est pour cette raison que
l'invasion l'annexion les politiques de
colonisation illégale doivent absolument
immédiatement cesser
nous continuerons de combattre la
violation du statut international de
jérusalem qui se fonde sur la résolution
des nations unies de 1947 nous
continuerons de lutter contre les
violations du caractère sain de haram al
sharif et pour les droits des peuples
palestiniens le processus de paix est la
vision de la solution des deux états
doivent retrouver un nouveau souffle et
ce dans les plus brefs délais
l'établissement d'un état indépendant
et d'un seul tenant de palestine avec
jérusalem comme capitale sur la base des
frontières de 1967
demeure une de nos priorités
des mesures importantes ont récemment
été prise
pour établir la stabilité dans le
caucase
en exerçant son droit à la légitime
défense l'azerbaïdjan a mis un terme à
l' invasion de son territoire
question qui a fait l'objet de
résolutions du conseil de sécurité
qui n'ont pas été appliquées pendant des
années
ce fait nouveau aussi permis
d'offrir de nouvelles possibilités
d'instaurer une paix durable dans la
région nous sommes déterminés à soutenir
toutes les mesures possibles
que pourraient prendre les parties
concernées nous accordons une grande
importance à la protection de
l'intégrité territoriale et de la
souveraineté de l'ukraine y compris la
crim est dont l'annexion n'est pas
reconnue par la turquie en ce qui
concerne l'intégrité territoriale de la
chine nous pensons que davantage
d'efforts sont nécessaires pour assurer
la protection des droits fondamentaux
des turcs ouïghours musulmans
nous restons favorables au règlement du
problème du cachemire qui dure depuis 74
ans au travers d'un dialogue entre les
parties et dans le cadre des différentes
résolutions pertinentes des nations
unies nous soutenons aussi le retour sur
volontaire dans la dignité des musulmans
rohingya qui vit dans des conditions
très difficiles dans des camps au
bangladesh et au myanmar
le retour vers leur terre est
indispensable une solution équitable
durable et pérenne à la question
chypriote ne sera possible que sur la
base d'une approche axée sur les
résultats et réaliste à des dirigeants
des deux peuples de lille
les peuples que les nations unies
considèrent comme égaux peut s'adresser
à vous il n'est pas juste que l'autre
dirigeant ne puisse pas être entendu ici
même
pour qu'une solution soit trouvée nous
devons réaffirmer l'égalité souveraine
et le statut international égale du
peuple turc chypriote
co propriétaire de l'île nous soutenons
donc la nouvelle vision du peuple turc
chypriote
pour trouver une solution je demande à
la communauté internationale
d'étudier le point de vue des turcs
chypriotes noël ou pris dans un esprit
d'ouverture sans préjuger
préserver le calme
dans l'est de la méditerranée est dans
notre intérêt à tous nous espérons que
les problèmes en lien avec la
détermination des frontières maritimes
pourront être réglés dans le cadre du
droit international et des principes de
bonne des relations de bon voisinage
pour ce faire nous devons
commencer par
renoncer à
ce mépris de la turquie qui possède la
longue la plus longue côte dans la
méditerranée orientale notre proposition
d'organiser une conférence sur la l'est
de la méditerranée dans laquelle tous
les acteurs de la région pour être
associé au dialogue à la coopération
reste d'actualité nous pensons aussi que
les problèmes de la mer egée devrait
être réglée au travers d'un dialogue
bilatéral
nous restons aussi
déterminés à accéder à l'union
européenne nous sommes solidaires du
continent et de l'union africaine
aujourd'hui
puisant dans ses liens très profonds que
nous entretenons avec l'afrique depuis
descendent des
siècles c'est ainsi que nous poursuivons
nos efforts pour tenir la 3 le troisième
sommet de partenariat turquie afrique en
turquie dans un avenir proche grâce à
notre initiative l'asie nouvelle nous
consolidons la position unifiée de la
turquie entre l'europe et l'asie nous
accordons une grande importance au
développement des relations avec
l'amérique latine et les caraïbes
au plan bilatéral et multilatéral
la turquie a été et restera aux côtés
de tous ceux qui prennent des mesures en
faveur d'un monde plus sûr plus
pacifique plus prospère et plus
équitable pour chacune et chacun
mesdames et messieurs les représentantes
et représentants
alors que la terre abrite des millions
d'espèces vivantes
tout ce qu'elle souhaite c'est que l'on
respecte les équilibres de la nature en
les chances de cette générosité
malheureusement
l'humanité a utilisé de manière
irresponsable les ressources offertes
par la terre sur l'autel du progrès du
développement tout au long de notre
histoire
au terme de ce processus qui a duré des
siècles nous sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés à des menaces à 100%
anthropique des menaces qui mettent à
mal l'équilibré de la nature
ces problèmes peuvent être regroupées
sous différentes rubriques changement
climatique pollution atmosphérique que
pollution de l'eau problèmes de sécurité
alimentaire perte de biodiversité
ils atteignent de telles proportions
qu'ils risquent de
menacer notre avenir l'avenir entier de
l'humanité
parmi ces rubriques les changements
climatiques mérite une attention toute
particulière
en plus d'être un problème
environnemental ces changements
pourraient avoir des conséquences
irréparables être source de bien des
incertitudes les gaz à effet de serre
tels que le dioxyde de carbone méthane
l'oxydé nitreux qui ont augmenté de 50%
par rapport à la période préindustrielle
ont entraîné une augmentation des
températures mondiales depuis un certain
temps déjà des catastrophes surviennent
aux quatre coins du monde liée à
l'augmentation de 1,1 degré celsius des
températures par rapport aux niveaux pré
industriels
nous connaissons des événements
inhabituels des inondations en asie en
europe des ouragans en amérique des
sécheresses en afrique des feux dans le
bassin méditerranéen
des précipitations au sommet du
groenland et des chutes de neige dans le
désert
ces catastrophes
en dommages non seulement
l'environnement et les écosystèmes et
aussi menacent la vie les moyens de
subsistance les biens des populations en
bien des endroits
les populations se prépare déjà à migrer
à quitter leur maison
et pourtant le monde n'a toujours pas
trouvé de solution au problème des
réfugiés liées aux crises prolongées
comme en syrie en afghanistan
actuellement nous ne savons pas comment
faire face à la migration de centaines
de millions de personnes
du fait des sécheresses des pénuries
alimentaires et des événements
météorologiques
les conséquences les plus importantes
des changements climatiques se feront
sentir dans les centres
metropolit a par exemple la ville de new
york où nous sommes aujourd'hui
a vécu des jours extrêmement difficile
ils souffrent d'ouragan
géant en l'espace d'à peine deux
semaines lesquels ont entraîné des
précipitations
sans commune mesure
inédite depuis 5 500 ans la destruction
causée par les pluies en europe de
l'ouest
doit être
suivi de réparation en turquie
nous avons connu notre part de
difficultés mais nous avons trouvé des
solutions rapides et efficaces
une grande partie des infrastructures
mondiales découle de l'activité humaine
ces deux derniers siècles
ces infrastructures sont liés au
changement climatique
la poursuite de l'augmentation des
températures mondiales
signifie que les précipitations vont
être plus fortes nous devons trouver de
nouvelles solutions par exemple
il est aujourd'hui obligatoire en terme
d'urbanisme de tenir compte des
conséquences
des changements climatiques
il est un autre danger qui menace notre
monde les forêts parmi les plus de
carbone et plus importants sont
confrontés à la disparition du fait de
l'utilisation du foncier et des feux il
est un autre domaine affecté par
l'augmentation des températures je veux
parler des mers et des océans
l'accélération de la fonda fonte des
glaciers entraîné une augmentation du
niveau des mers de 20 centimètres depuis
100 ans ce chiffre est le plus élevé
depuis 300 depuis 3000 ans
si les mesures efficaces ne sont pas
prises et que les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre continuent d'augmenter
l'élévation du niveau des mers va se
poursuivre pour dépasser un mètre d'ici
la fin de ce siècle cette augmentation
pourrait signifie qu'une grande partie
des villes côtières et des états
insulaires seront purement et simplement
rayés de la carte bien entendu cette
situation s'accompagnera aussi
de nouvelles vagues de migrations
massives
j'aimerais attirer votre attention sur
le fait que tous ces problèmes sont
survenus
avec une augmentation d'à peine 1,1
degré celsius des températures je vous
laisse imaginer ce qu'il pourrait se
passer
si cette augmentation des températures
atteignent et 1,5 degré au 2° celsius ou
plus
mesdames et messieurs les représentantes
et représentants
à la lumière de tout ce qui précède
nous et à dumont nous sommes réunis
avons uni nos efforts en 2015 pour
lutter contre les changements
climatiques et
avons adopté l'accord de paris sur les
changements climatiques
cet accord vise à limiter l'augmentation
des températures mondiales à 1,5 degré
celsius d'ici le milieu du siècle
cependant
la situation actuelle
ne va pas le permettre si des mesures ne
sont pas prises
les pays vont avant tout et surtout
devoir agir lorsqu'ils sont responsables
au plan historique de ces problèmes et
ont mené aux changements climatiques ils
vont devoir assumer leurs
responsabilités il sera peut être
possible
de stopper la pandémie de coronavirus
grâce aux vaccins qui ont été mises au
point mais on ne pourra pas espérer
trouver une solution au laboratoire au
changement climatique c'est pour cette
raison que
tout comme pour les changements
climatiques nous répétons notre
appel et cette devise que nous n'avons
de cesse de rappeler le monde ne se
limite pas à cinq pays ceux qui ont le
plus endommagé la nature l'atmosphère
notre eau notre sol notre terre ceux qui
ont sauvagement exploiter les ressources
naturelles devraient hausse
y apporter la plus grande contribution à
la lutte contre les changements
climatiques
aujourd'hui contrairement au passé
personne ne peut plus se dire je suis
puissant donc je ne vais pas payer la
facture le changement climatique
traite chacune et chacun de manière très
équitable
changement climatique vous traite de la
même manière que vous soyez européens
asiatiques américains africains riches
ou pauvres
ils nous ont incombe à tous et toutes de
prendre des mesures contre cette menace
énorme nous devons partager le fardeau
et nous acquitter de nos obligations
sans tarder la turquie agi dans ce sens
nous sommes parmi les premiers pays à
avoir signé l'accord de paris sur le
climat cependant
nous n'avons pas encore ratifié du fait
des injustices en lien avec les
obligations
connexes j'aimerais annoncer ici au
monde entier depuis la tribune de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
la décision que nous avons prise
suite aux progrès récemment enregistrés
nous avons l'intention de présenter
l'accord de paris sur le climat pour
approbation à notre parlement le mois
prochain dans le cadre de notre
contribution prévue déterminée au niveau
national et dans le droit fil des
mesures positives que nous allons
prendre avant la conférence des nations
unies sur les changements climatiques
qui aura lieu à glasgow nous prévoyons
d'achever la ratification de l'accord
ciblée sur la neutralité carbone
ce processus qui mènera à des
changements radicaux dans les domaines
de l'investissement de la production et
de l'emploi
est pour nous un élément phare de notre
vision 2050 3 bien entendu nous avons
prévu d'autres mesures pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques
nous avons préparé un plan d'action
en vue de l'harmonisation avec
l'accord de l'union européenne le green
deal
il est entré en vigueur il y à peu
grâce au projet zéro déchet lancé par la
1ère dan emine erdogan nous avons
augmenté le taux de recyclage de neuf
points en trois ans nous avons amélioré
aussi les puits en
améliorant la couverture forestière
qui est passée de 22 8 millions
d'hectares à quelque 23 millions
d'hectares nous avons accru la part des
sources d'énergie renouvelable dans
l'autre bouquet énergétique
elle atteint à présent 53% nous
encourageons les mesures qui vont
permettre de restructurer notre
industrie
rendre les activités de production plus
propres
nous sommes déterminés à poursuivre ses
efforts grâce au soutien financier dont
nous avons besoin la turquie n'est pas
indifférente aux problèmes mondiaux aux
crises aux appels lancés et fera sa part
en matière de changement climatique de
protection d'environnement mesdames et
messieurs avant de conclure je dirais
une fois encore a insisté sur le fait
que nous pensons qu'il est possible de
créer un monde plus équitable en dépit
des difficultés auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés ainsi donc nous continuons de
considérer les nations unies comme une
enceinte unique pour régler les
problèmes qui touchent
l'intégralité de l'humanité la nouvelle
maison de la turquie qui se situe en
face de l'onu et que nous avons inauguré
hier atteste de la confiance que nous
plaçons dans le système des nations
unies en tant que pays doté d'un des
cinq réseaux diplomatiques les plus
vastes au monde nous sommes très
présents sur le terrain et à la table
des négociations pour trouver des
solutions équitables en toute conscience
de par le monde nous pouvons faire
advenir un monde de paix de stabilité de
prospérité et de bonheur ensemble
une fois encore
je vous adresse au nom de ma nation non
plus sincères salutations et souhaiter
plein succès à la 66e session de
l'assemblée générale
je vous souhaite à tous et à toutes
lassant des
ambulances les deux relais au nom de
l'assemblée générale je souhaite
remercier le président de la république
dur que pour la déclaration
il vient d'être prononcé je prie les
services du protocole
de raccompagner son excellence